now we turn to some breaking news out of
ukraine russia now on the brink of a
full-scale invasion joe biden says he
has a bold new plan to bring peace to
europe uh by the way this just broke
apparently i'm hearing from sources that
the u.s might be
meeting and talking with russia next
week but today he sent a very competent
vice president kamala harris to germany
apparently to get to the bottom of the
root cause of this russian aggression on
ukraine's border she has zero foreign
policy experience and after a wildly
successful stint as our borders are i'm
sure this is this is going to go great
now one quick question
why not the president himself perhaps
another trip abroad is more than he can
handle at this stage of his life either
way this comes on the heels of a lot of
pointless posturing from the biden
administration okay great they took 8
500 troops and put them on a heightened
state of preparedness they sent an
additional 3 000 troops to poland okay
you know joe already said he's not
getting into a shooting war and let me
be clear nor should he but he said that
publicly if he really wants to squeeze
putin there is a plan that we should be
implementing and this would work prevent
if you want to prevent the invasion of
ukraine joe needs to communicate to
vladimir immediately should have done it
on day one that we will out pump him we
will produce more energy than him and we
will get it to our
allies in western europe quickly and
more cheaply and by the way that means
oil that means coal that means natural
gas of course unfortunately joe is
beholden to the climate change cultists
in his own party so i can only say that
you know that would be the way to
[ __ ] russia's economy because oil and
gas
is like their only industry that's not
going to happen he takes orders from the
climate change called caucus anyway
joining us now former secretary of state
mike pompeo is with us
now maybe i'm old-fashioned but i
believe in peace through strength
and why do i think it's a bad idea to be
begging and pleading with joe
uh with vladimir putin while he has a
hundred and fifty to two hundred
thousand troops and all his military
gear on the border of ukraine
uh why do i see that as a position of
weakness on our part am i wrong
sean you're absolutely right and thanks
for having me on tonight uh we've
demonstrated weakness with respect to
the russians for the entire what now 14
months of this administration it began
by giving them a free pass on a nuclear
treaty where we extracted nothing we let
them close down gasoline pipelines in
the southeast of the united states we we
did nothing we let them finish nordstrom
2 we lifted the trump sanctions on
nordstrom 2. and then we did the the the
worst thing we shut down american
natural gas and crude oil production
giving vladimir putin 100 bucks a barrel
or 93 bucks a barrel uh for the crude
oil that's produced in russia we put his
economy on super warp and we harmed ours
and lost jobs here at home these are all
things i think vladimir putin saw very
quickly your point about climate change
the first senior american to visit with
vladimir putin in the bite
administration was secretary kerry not
the secretary of state but the climate
czar i think that sent a real message to
putin and i think we're seeing the
results of that today i thought it was
humiliating and embarrassing with joe
basically begging putin to let let's
meet there's still time we can have
discussions
diplomacy can still work etc etc why are
you begging a guy that's lined up 150
plus thousand troops to invade a
sovereign country by the way i'm no fan
of ukraine when i look at ukraine i see
pretty much corruption everywhere and i
see the same thing with the hostile
regime in russia under putin but so i
don't think it's america's role but
i do think that he has made a strategic
mistake by not
supplying our allies in western europe
considering we have more natural
resources when it comes to gas oil and
coal than vladimir putin and by
abandoning energy independence he has
now pushed our allies right into putin's
arms hasn't he
yeah sean this is an easy one we have
cheap affordable energy here at home and
we have the capacity to ship it at a
really good cost to our european friends
and allies we should we should be
crushing the russians with this but you
know the same time we're having this
conversation with the russians in europe
we're sitting on the same side of the
table sean the same side of the table
with the russians in
vienna talking about giving the iranians
the very same capacity to ship their
product their crude oil their natural
gas around the world
this is an enormous sign of weakness
this is a failure of american foreign
policy in the fundamental deterrence
sense that reagan had and that we had
for our four years i saw this up close
and personal sergey lav lavrov will eat
our secretary of state's lunch if we
don't demonstrate american resolving the
capacity and willingness to do the right
things for our friends what are the odds
on these three issues what are the odds
in the next year putin invades ukraine
what are the odds that the iranians get
a nuclear weapon what are the odds that
after the olympics china will quote
reunify meaning take over taiwan in your
view
you know it's a great question i think
in some sense all three of them are well
along in happening the russians have
already connected in ukraine they took
crimea under the previous democrat
administration they're making a lot of
noise in the donbass today firing
rockets as well
in iran
we've already essentially lifted
sanctions not by actually lifting them
but failing to enforce them and we've
allowed iran to get very close to having
a not only a nuclear weapon but a
missile program so that they can deliver
it and make no mistake about it xi
jinping can see this weakness too he saw
the debacle in afghanistan he's going to
move closer and coaster and continue to
try and put a stranglehold on taiwan
that does not bode well for freedom and
democracy on that island you're saying
things on all three fronts are not
looking good am i hearing you right
american weakness always creates risk
for our friends and ultimately for
american interests as well sean
yeah no mike pompeo i wish you were
still i wish the adults were back in
charge i wish you were there thank you
uh for being with us we appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else